ein programm mit zurück bei vielen
nachts schön ist dann sind wir wollen
jetzt direkt mit der frage weiter machen
ob meine gäste von der gefahr eines
dritten weltkrieges überzeugt sind denn
das haben wir heute noch zu wenig
gesprochen da möchte ich direkt bei
hairkiller starten denn immer wenn wir
über die ukraine reden und über russland
als aggressor ist und ich auch immer die
frage was könnte es für deutschland
bedeuten und diese angst bewegt dieses
land wie hoch schätzen sie denn die
chancen dass putin den dritten weltkrieg
ausgelöst naja ich hoffe dass er diese
chance an sich vorbeigehen lässt also
ist zwischen lehrern risiko als eine
chance
es ist sein negativ ist seine erzählung
er droht und la france drohen mit der
atombombe wir kennen aus dem kalten
krieg das gleichgewicht des schreckens
besteht darin jetzt heißt es genau die
jetzt wieder heiß ist aber das
gleichgewicht des kalten krieges bestand
darin dass die andere seite eben damit
auch tun kann also ich glaube wenn man
sehr die gefahr sehe ich eben sowohl in
diesem brief als auch in manchen
debatten wenn man zu ducken äußeres so
leisetreter risch auf nach dem motto oh
gott oh gott der andere kann was ganz
ganz schlimmes tun es müssen wir uns
alle in die höhle zurückziehen und
gucken hoffen dass das ungewitter über
unseren köpfen dahin zieht und wieder
trockenen fußes in die friedens ära
hinaus gehen können das halte ich für
gefährlich dass die gefahr einer
eskalation ihn zum atomkrieg ist da aber
ich würde auf gar keinen fall jetzt hier
eins zu eins für bare münze dieses
szenario von helmut ii nehmen ich würde
mich da wirklich nicht ins bockshorn
jagen lassen im zweifelsfalle kann auch
frankreich als atommacht russland
vernichten als was könnt ihr dann hatten
die wahrscheinlichkeit gibt es dann gebe
aber ich sehe dass weder morgen noch
übermorgen diese selbstmörderischen
aktion wird sich letzten endes auch
keine russische führung jetzt überlegen
die frage ist nur ob man einschalten
dieses spiel und die eine seite sagt ich
tue und die andere seite sagt ich habe
angst und lass mich von lisa strom ins
bockshorn jagen lassen das ist glaube
ich die gefahr dass man zu sehr zum
büttel wird der propaganda von herrn
putin wenn man diese drohung sehr ernst
nimmt letztendlich spielt er genauso mit
der vernichtung russlands wenn man die
drohungen anstehen habe wie eben auch
die vernichtung des westens eingepreist
sein müsste in dem russischen ärzten
szenario das heißt da müssen wir uns von
frei machen von diesen szenarien und
wenn herr abruf der jetzt sogar zur zur
exegese verstiegen hat in herrn hitler
sei jüdisches blut zu finden also wenn
man die güte der verheißungen von
daimler auch für bare münze nehmen dann
glaube ich dann sind wir wirklich also
im phantasialand oder in der geisterbahn
also wirklich das als szenario nehmen
und ein wort noch zur eskalation
momentan eskaliert natürlich herr putin
ganz massiv also der kriegstreiber ist
herr putin und es sollten natürlich auch
bei allen historischen exkursen die wir
selbst wenn dich führen können nicht in
relativierende absicht hinzufügen also
nicht der ist die eskalieren ist nicht
herr steingart oder sonst jemand der
sache müssen die ukraine bewaffnete
eskalierend ist momentan an
lebensmitteln um das auch noch mal ganz
deutlich auch für alle zuhörer und vor
allem schön brüder zu sagen wenn ich
dabei das unterschreibe ich völlig ja
und trotzdem ist natürlich so eine
sprechtag setzung also dieses der dritte
weltkrieg und dann dieses eingreifen
weil wir müssen in den dritten weltkrieg
um ihn zu verhindern das sind natürlich
sprechakte also ich glaube schon dass
man sich auch in so eine sache
hineinsteigern kann und das wollte ich
gar nicht sagen der einzige satz den ich
machen möchte ist vorüber mir zu wenig
nachgedacht wird und ich sitze hier
wirklich als jemand der fundamental
eigentlich seit 30 jahren darauf worte
dass europa sich als kontinent
emanzipiert das war 1989 die absicht das
flotte hat den großartigen aufsatz
geschrieben falls europa erwacht wir
wollten nach 89 eine neue
friedensordnung der kalte krieg war vor
über das war eigentlich die absicht ja
und ich habe das gefühl dass wir jetzt
im grunde das alles abräumen und das
aber in dieser frage die amerikanischen
und die europäischen interessen nicht
kongruent sind wenn ich mir angucke was
jede form des krieges und der eskalation
für europa bedeutet also die sozialen
verwerfungen europa ist doch schon bald
weiterbauen
italien ist es sehr unterschiedlich aber
wie auch immer das nuclear fallout wenn
es welche geben würde wäre hier und
nicht auf detroit und new york das heißt
wir haben doch ganz andere interessen
wirklich sieht all fliegen können
ja das hat er ganz klar gesagt ja wir
sind das battlefield und das noch mal zu
den begriff dritter weltkrieg ja auch
der erste und der zweite weltkrieg waren
letztendlich europäische kriege die
haben hier stattgefunden mit ein
bisschen in der sahara und ein bisschen
in japan aber weltkrieg heißt eigentlich
ist das battlefield ja ein bisschen herr
wissen und gibt bullische sinn wenn ein
kontinent leidet dann ist es dieser
kontinent deswegen möchte ich nun gehört
das ja und deswegen möchte ich sagen in
einem krieg wenn man ihn nicht beendet
gibt es interessen und die interessen
sind woanders zu suchen ja es gibt ja
auch viele theorien wenn sie einmal ins
internet gehen dass das natürlich ein
proxy krieg ist ja china amerika was
auch immer da ausgefochten wird ein
amerikanischer oder chinesische
vorherrschaft wie auch immer und
deswegen müssen wir doch wenn wir jetzt
mal ge und im geostrategisch nachdenken
noch mal fragen worum geht es hier was
ist das ziel wer verdient an diesem
krieg wer will ihn beenden tour de ski
wm genau
und sei nicht schneiden wir so ein ring
ist ein gutes stichwort herr bruder wie
können wir denn den krieg beenden wir
können den trick überhaupt nicht beenden
wir haben ihn nicht angefangen den krieg
beenden kann nur putin in dem er seine
jungs zurückruft und zwar möglichst bald
und möglichst in gänze und er würde
damit auch vieler russischer leben
inzwischen retten und ich weiß überhaupt
nicht woher hier in diesem lande die das
verständnis für putin kommt vergessen
sie mal ukraine schauen sie sich nur an
was putin mit seinem eigenen land macht
wie er die meinungsfreiheit waren wir
bürgern einfacher werden sollten
umgehend wo er reicht das schon um mir
einen regime change in moskau zu
wünschen dazu hat er nicht die ukraine
über fallen müssen aber ihre aufregung
und die ihre freunde und dieser naiven
menschlichen brief unterzeichnet haben
geht um den punkt dass wir imstande
wären einen dritten weltkrieg zu
verhindern
wir sind bei ständer wir haben dann
vielleicht nicht alle ihre fantastische
wohl glauben einzelne weltkrieg könnte
kommen wenn man sollte das laufen mitten
im dritten weltkrieg bereit sind einen
weltkrieg muss nicht so romantisch
anfangen wie der erste weltkrieg mit dem
attentat von sarajewo wir sind mit den
dritten weltkrieg und er wird mit
anderen mitteln ausgetragen im cyber
findet der längs statt und es geht jetzt
einfach um die frage wohin gleichen
dieser dritte weltkrieg war wer wer geht
da gerade gegen chile im krieg gibt
keine planungssicherheit ich weiß nur
dass wir jetzt im krieg haben wohin geht
weiß ich nicht also ich hab sie uns
regional oder nicht gesehen das wusste
er genau paulus bei stalingrad auch
nicht wie es enden würde also ich sehe
einen russisch-ukrainischen krieg aber
noch kein dritten weltkrieg wo sehen sie
die schön dass ich nicht sehen aber wenn
sie sagen sie sehen ihn schon möchte ich
wissen wo sie den sehen ich will nachher
privat ist es okay ja sagt gut
vielleicht
die aufreihung die deag ist beklagt und
die der brief aber letztlich bin ich
kein bild machen kann doch nicht wahr
war warum kaprizieren wir uns befinden
hitler vergleicht problematisch richtig
wir sollten auch mit der vokabel
weltkrieg finde ich an der stelle ein
bisschen vorsichtiger umgehen also wir
haben einen massiven konflikt und ich
fahre gut dass sie auch im cyber
einflussnahme auf an allen möglichen
enden an spielen wir haben genau ich
viel zu lange europäisch ignoriert
einflussnahme chinas auf europa ist ob
die amerikanischen raum auf den
südamerikanischen auf dem pazifischen
raum also wir haben und seine
herrschaftsansprüche von aggressoren
überall auf der welt genau interessiert
uns vor allen dingen deshalb auch sie
persönlich ja gesagt weil es vor unserer
haustür stattfindet die richtig ja aber
wenn wir unabhängig davon was er die
ukraine attestieren oder nicht
attestieren uns einig sind dass sie über
fallenden sind das wird im krieg in der
tat nicht selbst beenden können weil
putin begonnen hat und wenn uns aber
vollkommen klar ist dass wir nicht
tatenlos zusehen wollen wie putin voran
marschiert im übrigen lange angekündigt
mit einer großen zustimmung im eigenen
land versehen mit einer propaganda der
mutter bin ja eher so kann israel und
seiner sicht sei rational und jeder der
die ddr und russische propaganda zu ddr
zeiten erlebt hat und ich habe dir als
kind ein jugendlicher noch sehr gut in
meinem ohr und ich habe in russland
selbst erlebt wie das regime sich nicht
geändert hat der kann nicht im unklaren
darüber sein wie putin ihren aber traut
ihr gelernt sich denn hier kleine
zuschauer man sich online wie erklären
sie sich denn dann die enge nähe ihrer
ex partei der afg zu russland ja auch
sie mit den linken das gemeinsam
haushalten grund warum ist eine ex
partei ist es beantwortet die frage das
ist sogar ein ja dazu
ich war einmal vorsitzende aber diese
art von politik die sie heute betreibt
und nicht nur zum thema ostern noch zu
ganz weit 2017 zum wein trank ich nicht
mit das wurde immer gerne interpretiert
dass ich in russland war und dass sich
personen dort getroffen habe die heute
immer noch putins nähe sind und wie ein
sehr eigenes bild machen durfte das
unter anderem dazu beiträgt dass ich
heute genau den standpunkt vertrete den
ich hier heute abend vertreten das hat
seine gründe und ich kann aus meiner
eigenen persönlichen erfahrung sagen
russland damals noch sowjetunion zu ddr
zeiten hat sich nicht geändert es hat
mir eine demokratische straße gegeben da
war der feudalismus sache war der
kommunismus heute haben wir putins
regime und das hat natürlich auch die
menschen in diesem riesigen land
natürlich auswirkungen gehabt das heißt
eine regime change gutem weg wurde noch
nicht einmal viel bewirken
wir wissen dass die zustimmung zu putins
großmachtpolitik groß ist zumindest so
groß dass es ihnen weiter oder sammer
politiker seiner couleur weiter an der
macht halten wird das heißt als einzige
ziel kann darin bestehen seinen
vormarsch zu begrenzen und das werden
wir kister da bin ich bin ich bei ihnen
das werden wir nicht über jahre und
jahrzehnte führen controls dem muss uns
auch klar sein dass dieser krieg in drei
wochen nicht vorbei sein wird es wird
also noch eine weile gehen und die frage
die wiener entscheiden können helfen wir
den überfallenen tun was nicht und da
ist meine antwort ganz können wir auch
an einen sozusagen russland ohne putin
oder nach putin uns vorstellen ein
demokratisches russland auf dass wir hin
wirken wollten es gab also bei allem was
sie aufgezählt haben sozusagen die
langen phasen des russischen
totalitarismus ja gab es immerhin mal
die phase nach 89 wo wir versucht haben
das hat ungefähr zehn zwölf jahre
gedauert da wollten wir etwas anderes
putin stand vor dem bundestag es gab
standing ovations werden an den ksc
ordnung wir hatten zumindest die absicht
das labor genau so verstanden ja so aber
diese phase ist schief gelaufen da
müsste man mal analysieren warum
eigentlich ja werte eigentlich was
gewollt und so weiter nur die firma
gekommen was auch immer jedenfalls zu
fragen ist doch immer noch was ist die
friedensordnung die wir danach wollen
und diese frage stelle ich mir nicht
mehr wirklich aber ist das nicht ein
bisschen sie sagen ganz ganz weit in ein
realistisch wenn wir jetzt sagen hier
das ist mal ganz realistische russia 3
also ich frage mich was ist denn das
jetzt für die strategie wenn wir sagen
russland muss total ausgetrocknet wäre
total
natürlich schon dann hat hier niemand
gesagt habe ich nicht gehört hatte hier
in dieser runde noch
da sagt völliges ökonomisches
sozusagen die sanktionen auch niemals
erreichen
das ist ein vertrages nicht funktioniert
hat heute auch nicht das ist genau die
frage um die es jetzt geht ja deswegen
geht es ja um die frage ob für fracking
gas bekommen oder den gashahn zudrehen
und so weiter und so weiter trotzdem
würde ich noch immer noch mal darauf
hinwirken wollen dass wir ein kontinent
sind der doch einen also eine
eurasischen friedens entwurf hat da
könnte doch nicht sagen dass wir jetzt
die mauer die wir 89 hatten jeweils
anderen klamotten tragen inzwischen
trage ganz verwehrt schon über die neue
ordnung sprechen nach inklusion ist die
frage aktuell 80 prozent der russen in
russland sind ja für putin da kommt
natürlich die frage auch gerne an sie
beide können wir jetzt gerade überhaupt
schon darüber nachdenken was nach putin
basiert und wie wir mit ihnen
zusammenarbeiten werden egal was nach
gut es ist ganz ganz schwierig aber ich
bin ich ja dabei ja also die frage ist
ja wir glauben ja immer oder zumindest
es gibt es einige die glauben dass wenn
wir jetzt sozusagen hart genug mit putin
sind dass wir dann die opposition gegen
putin in russland eigentlich
mobilisieren ja das halte ich auch
tatsächlich für unrealistisch und ich
glaube dass wir das gegenteil tun dass
je mehr wir putin sozusagen in die enge
treiben desto mehr wird der proto
faschismus der oder nationalismus länder
unterwegs ist weil du ihn sich dann da
ist ja meinungs- unterdrückung gebe ich
ihnen ja völlig recht ja dann stellt
sich alles
absolut so bin ich auch dabei und desto
mehr wird man dann natürlich wird putin
sich hinstellen können seht was der west
mit mehr macht und wird im prinzip genau
diese
verschieben lassen doch nicht besser ihn
machen zu lassen
gar nichts sie füttern das krokodil in
der hoffnung gewerbe sie als letzten
fressen sie prügeln und glauben mit
immer mehr prügeln gibt's weniger nein
nein nein nein ich habe die prügel nicht
angefangen wissen sie es ist jetzt eine
art von wegscheider wer es ist der
moment der in münchen 38 stattfand als
hitler genau wusste und dafür gleich
ganz bewusst dass man ihm alles
durchgehen lässt und wenn der nächste
china mit der atombombe droht wenn alle
europäischen länder ihre beziehungen zu
taiwan nicht abbrechen wenn der tee run
auf die idee kommt wieder atombombe zu
drohen wenn die europäische union ihre
beziehungen mit israel nicht einstellt
dann wird das das ergebnis und sondern
sage wie der marder panzern design
strahlengang nach china oder die
parallel dahin ja es werden dann unsere
strategie also sagen wir bleiben auch
mal bei diesem china taiwan finde ich
total interessant ja also china
entscheidet sich jetzt auch wir
schnappen uns mal gerade teil waren
sie sind kurz davor so etwas machen wir
dann fangen wir mit marder panzern
online stellen lasse jedoch darauf
gewinne lassen wir gewähren solange die
wir hier unser bier trinkt aber dann
sind wir uns ja nicht
eine frage würde irgendwie spd eintreten
dass mit ihnen eigentlich seien aber
eher bruder oder ihr prinzip eine einer
tagen um die kamera aus die
wurden ja